I love Madonna moment oh thanks yes I
didn't know what to like dress as I'm
like losing my identity I'm like what do
I do today so this was the look I was
going for I'm not Italian either
everyone keeps asking me like are you
Italian like everywhere I went today
right that's exactly it you get it yeah
and no one else literally nobody else
I've got it I've never seen Esther so
happy I saw her post today and I
instantly listed blasted Papa Don't
Preach on my way here I'm like I'm
getting in the mood I love it I love
that you know that's why we're soulmates
like I really do feel connected to you
when I text you as I connected oh thanks
yeah girls wearing this every girl wears
like Alex girl wears these and like
those are so cute we're so blessed that
you have been dressing as a McDonald's
employee lately
you having like
like well go watch it yes there's a lot
of content for you but you okay your
husband's so much like my boyfriend
where it's like you just have like a
person there that's just like there to
make you happy and do all of your things
it's the best I've never had something
like that ever in my life and he just
goes along with everything and he's just
so great he's like happy to do it too
it's like you're like he's dragging to
do he like loves to do it yeah it's
really fun I love that you watched it
because that's with one camera we did
buy microphones for that though we did
get like microphones and yeah Trisha how
is life since becoming the mother to the
most beautiful little Malibu Barbie I've
ever seen oh my God thank you first of
all is so amazing it's so fun I mean
it's it is like a lot of work but it's
like literally so much fun like I
literally like can't get any work done
like I just have like so much fun with
her she's like a doll and I know like
whatever you're not like supposed to say
that but she's like a little doll that
you dress up because we were like babies
aren't dolls that you just dress up and
like literally that's what I do with my
baby all day it's like dress her up and
she's so cute I just I love it it's like
been the best thing ever I like this I
usually bring her with me like I brought
her to like the Zach saying show like I
usually bring her with me everywhere but
I was like let me just like not bring
the baby everywhere because it's like
Esther are we not gonna be those types
of moms where we're like praying like
Natasha legere our friend brought her
baby pretty much on stage with her like
she had the baby yeah she had the baby
in like one of those like things that
goes in the car and you can take it out
I love it I think I've decided if I have
a baby that I probably won't ever really
meet it like
motherhood
you do you just push it out and then
like drop it at my doorstep
I'm eyeing a few people oh my gosh
I have embryo so I'm just gonna give her
my embryos I would love one of your
embryos
I think you'd be okay on my shoulders
you might change your mind I have two
you've been saying all of these years
that you love my broad shoulders it
turns out both of my shoulders according
to an orthopedic surgeon today are [__]
shoulders they're both gone that's what
the doctor says grade four chondrosis I
was like you're telling me
chondrosis he was like bone on bone [__]
shoulders is what he said oh my gosh I
just got horny
you're gonna be so jealous but he says
I've this is usually like an old person
thing and also you need like soulmates
total shoulder replacement
did you hear that shoulder is there no
you can't do like you could have mine
can't Joe dispenser your shoulders back
but they did say he did say there's
another um procedure called oats where
they can get
um cartilage from
um uh a dead person oh and put it in my
um shoulders if you love her or not kill
yourself you have to give your shoulders
to her first of all I would give my
shoulders alive and well
um
I really want something to go wrong with
me where I need to take something from a
dead person like that I want to have
like well the idea truly excited me
because I'm like oh what extra shoulder
I can give you some I would love it wait
what part did they put in they put in a
skin or a bone into your shoulder in
between the socket where the cartilage
is basically gone so they take cartilage
from uh yeah from a deady and then they
put it in there Barbara Walters is fresh
oh my gosh did she die oh yeah
you're kind of excited
but people write like that's the problem
with death like I know when I die people
will be happy and like that's the
problem no of course they will be it's
like people were like excited like
Barbara Walters was like you know this
this and this and she like criticized
Brooke Shields and people get like so
nasty about people when they die and I'm
like I have so many things for me to ask
me about but I didn't know she died
that's so sad what she died of just old
I think she was 93. yeah it was time but
rip to a legend we would love to mine
some of her cartilage
John
but here's about Barbara Walters I watch
this clip of her doing uh an old
interview with Dolly Parton and it was
the first time where I genuinely hated
her she can be a [__] yeah her
interviews were crazy yeah but no but
doesn't that kind of make a good
interview when someone pushes a little
that's what all interviews are and
that's when you're like this being a
reporter is like such a weird [__] up
job this is why Madonna hates
journalists right famously I remember I
was a journalism student and I basically
dropped out of school because she said
that their apples I'm a student because
what you thought you were going to be
like welcome to Fox I don't know what I
thought but I quit that's so funny I
could see it being like the weather girl
they put you on an Apple box you know
what's so funny I don't know if you guys
have seen these clips but in covid you
know how like the news anchors are doing
their news from home or they were
there's like a guy doing the weather and
his dog like kept getting into the frame
like rooting the green screen yeah like
a green screen in his house doing it
yeah that's everything I would love to
be a weather girl but I feel like you
have to go to college for it or no like
you can do
[Laughter]
Esther give me your shoulders I'm
putting them in here
thank you to our sponsor ZocDoc ZocDoc
is the only free app that lets you find
and book doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance are
available when you need them and treat
almost every condition Under the Sun go
to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com trash zocdoc.com trash
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
that you want to if you want to live a
more empowered life therapy can get you
there visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help help.com trash
Tuesday Tuesday are you looking to kick
start a keto diet in the New Year we're
making it easier than ever before to
keep keto with our brand new limited
time keto kickoff 2023. now you can find
keto recipes for breakfast lunch and
dinner plus meal bundles at the Green
Market keep keto the easy and delicious
way go to greenchef.com trash tuesday60
and use code trash tuesday60 to get 60
off plus free shipping that's
greenchef.com trash tuesday60 and use
code trash tuesday60 to get 60 off plus
free shipping green Chef the number one
meal kit for eating well hi guys you can
see me uh January 27th and January 28th
at Madison at Communion State at Madison
in Madison Dania Beach Florida February
3rd and 4th Washington DC February 24th
and 25th Seattle Washington March 10th
and 11th Tampa Florida March 17th and
18th and there's a lot more dates go to
annieleterman.com shows you can also see
my solo podcast Annie wood every
Thursday I do a live chat with everyone
when it premieres it's so fun I love it
come over there if you want a little
extra Annie
peace hi stand up friends you can see me
I'm coming to Florida April 21st I will
be in Miami get tickets at
estheronice.com and check out my new
solo podcast my pleasure wherever you
listen to audio it's very strange
[Music]
oh my God look at all your props what's
all happening over there that says well
we used to be called bloodbath and then
so as a present Pete our beautiful P
Predator Pete
don't let him run her daughter
um yeah babies
um
he's the least predatory person out of
here but he got the nickname but that's
why we call him yeah why why though uh
well during our live show we were being
sexual and Pete was there so I guess he
got blamed for it I think he said like
pervy P why do they say Predator that's
so aggressive so good it just yeah yeah
like just waiting for Chris Hanson to
bust in with some cookies that's a show
I miss I miss Chris Hanson he's got a
new one out on yeah oh
[Laughter]
I didn't know he was such a fan girl
Madonna I taught an extracurricular
class in college called Madonna 101. we
I made it to dolls
teddy bears the participants were not
willing you are correct I had to force
my friends to make it an official Club
to get like the right number of people
to let the college so that the college
would let us rent a room out I can't
believe you dropped out when you had all
this ambition
post iconic tours
um are you like are you you seem like
you're probably a pretty serious Madonna
girly right it's so funny like I wasn't
and then I feel like I found out
Brittany was a big Madonna fan when I
was like a teenager that's like I have
to become a Madonna fan so everything I
know is kind of like through Brittany
I'm not like the biggest like I don't
know too much but I do love the papa
Don't Preach like video in general and
the reason I found that song is because
of Kelly Osborne I like love her cover
so good so good yes everything and
that's the VMAs and she like ran down
the stairs and saying and I had no idea
it was Madonna's then I like watched the
video and I saw the video of Madonna was
like super sexual about having a baby
and stuff like I was like oh that's
everything like and then I like fell in
love so I'm like a huge like I do love
Madonna but like do you know what she
said she saw one of my videos Jesus and
should I had an Angelic voice Madonna
yeah I reacted to it on my thing I was
like super excited but it was under the
guise of tick tock live there was this
like comedian on Tic Tac lightning Terry
Joe and she was showing her the I love
you Jesus video saying it was her and
she oh your voice is really beautiful
but technically it was my voice so I was
like
I love Cherry yeah okay I love you love
you know I all day long it's just Terry
Joe all day long yeah the lives are
great I join in like lives at each type
I can she's like so comedically funny
like I cannot keep up with it like she's
so good she's such a good troll you guys
know Terry no I'm excited
so good how do you describe
um so she does these lives and she plays
as character of Terry Joe and she's
basically well she's well
how do we describe she's supposed to be
a Christian girl yes right right a Pious
girl but she is she gets on the lives
with Bob the drag queen Doja cat and
hilarious and Madonna she like does lots
of lives with Madonna it's crazy like
when Donnelly promised her a car and she
sent her like a little BMW like portal
like it's crazy like it's like Madonna
has like long chats with this person and
like she's like a troll like it's a
troll obviously like she's Christian but
then also talks about being like horny
and like being molested and all stuff
like that so it's like she's like a
troll it's like kind of it's like
interesting yeah I'm the top molested
Quaker
number one I have to be a top molested
something you're the top molested
Filipino swimmer yeah
Philip mermaid
I love that positive spin yes when I'm
on the road people be like where are
Esther and kalila I'm like Esther's
probably shooting a movie and kalila is
in the [__] ocean
sounds
I'm like she's not above water I'll tell
you that yeah
wait so you actually I have to say
because we know we were earlier joking
about like how I motherhood is scary
whatever I don't want to do it but you
have been giving me like Vibes that this
it could really you could really become
a mom love it and still be yourself like
do you feel that way yeah totally I
really did think I would change like you
know personality-wise and stuff like
that but anything I feel like if
anything like being like having a kid
makes you like want to be a kid even
more like I have so much on like every
time I dress up and like go upstairs she
like has the biggest Smiles on her face
like oh my God she thinks it's like so
cool and she's like four months and I'm
like how does she even know baby like
yeah like a baby like adult so it's like
perfect you get to dress up with your
baby so perfect it really is I'm like oh
my God everything matching like all the
Halloween costumes would be like six
Halloween costumes this year like
everything is great I love it it's like
it's literally so much fun and it's
weird like I always want to be a mom but
I like thought I would like like I said
be like being so different I think I
think it's hard to take care of a dog
than a child so if you have a dog I
think like it's so easy to take care of
her child I had a dog for one week and I
was like I gave it to my mom could not
do it it was so hard because they kind
of poop everywhere like babies are
contained poop and yeah it's not like
that bad maybe diapers for dogs
right saying you're saying I'm gonna be
an exceptional mom I have four [__]
dogs oh my God that's right and one of
them is like a violent dick biter oh my
God yeah you don't think you'd be a good
mom huh you don't think you'd be a good
mom you're a mommy yeah your mom would
[__] shoulders how am I gonna carry my
babies you can't train the dogs to carry
them
wait do you want kids do you want kids
yeah um or no yeah like I'm I I actually
do I wow but I um it's been a kind of a
testy subject because I never felt like
in my last relationship that I could be
um I don't know that we could be
successful parents together yeah but I
always had faith in my own ability but
only in the last like three years before
that I was like oh I am unhealed no
that's exactly how I felt so I was like
I will [__] A kid will die
I will be the leave it in the car girl
it's scary but if you have the right it
really is about the right partner
because like I I feel like I want to get
pregnant so many times with so many like
people that I like you know and it never
happened but I'm so glad it happened
with my husband because he is like such
like a like he really does do also like
helps out so much like he does like a
lot of the work and some people always
are like Moses takes care of that baby
I'm like well a dad like should baby
yeah you know what I mean my boyfriend
Todd will take care if he could burn the
kids he'd burn the kids yeah I'm like
hey you do it I love it I hate that
people like shame like guys who want to
take care of the kids they're like be
like a primary caregiver and stuff like
that it's like so crazy to me I'm like
he's so good but any other like person I
would have had a kid with would have
been like a disaster I would have like
lost my mind you know but if I need like
a break to go get like coffee for like
an hour like he's so good to just like
watch her and like don't even like
questions yeah you need to come home and
take it like he's so good like that even
like this he's just like go have fun
okay Trish I have a question for you
because this is something I've been
thinking about a while just like in my
own life and because we're the same age
and have very similar interests I want
to know if you relate like I feel like
we're gonna do this image you both give
baby like you lost elderly baby like
Benjamin Button when he's done she's
like fun happy baby
yeah she's like just like learning like
like looking at lights and stuff chicken
nuggets
um baby Vibes and like the best way I
see you on shows and you're always like
a little kid and that's like everything
thank you
um I feel like I'm realizing that I am a
millennial in age but like a gen Z in
spirit I feel like I'm connecting with
the Gen Z generation so much more I feel
so much more similar to them do you also
feel this thousand percent I just did a
collab yesterday with like um these tick
tockers they're like 21 or something
like that they're on the new season of
RuPaul's Drag Race and like literally
they were so like young and like
everything I was like oh yeah me too I
just felt like I was like part of them
like I knew everything that they were
talking about and relating to asking the
Stanley Cups was getting the mini Uggs I
was like yeah I like feel like I'm one
of you it's so weird because like my
generation of YouTubers are so like just
over social media oh social media is
awful and so hard and like this new
generation is just like all about it
embracing it I love everything about it
yeah I gotta roll with it it's like why
do you get me against the movement of
Life yeah surrender go with the Peace of
least resistance yes it's fun Paula
Abdul is really good at keeping up with
the new generation I was all over Tick
Tock yeah she's like they've literally
heard people like contact me like do you
want to do like a mukbang with Paula
Abdul and I see her everywhere now and I
was like that's everything she's really
like killing the game I met her at the
comedy store she follows me on Instagram
oh let's get her on here
um yeah my brother my twin brother and I
were like obsessed with her we had a
cousin who ended up being gay but we
didn't know when we were kids but he was
obsessed with Madonna and Paula Abdul so
we have ones we would hang out with him
it was like we're that's all we were
obsessed with too we just copied him I
have a question for you Esther since you
never um inherited any family heirlooms
are there any is there anything in your
life right now that you plan on passing
on to your child that you're keeping
safe because I know that was a really
big pain point the Prada shoes iconic
good question well
um I think every all of my stuff they
have to preserve I would love to I would
my ideal scenario in life would be to
like be able to keep my childhood home
and like have that I feel like the only
reason I want to have a kid is so that
someone can inherit that house from me
because you don't want to actually live
in it you want to be in the basement yes
you're a basement dweller you're not
you're not sleeping in a room yes I want
Mommy wants to live in your basement
baby but what are your thoughts like on
me saying that I only want one do you
feel like oh that'll make sense or do
you think my mind will change no I think
that makes so much I'm on Tick Tock
right now where it's one and done I
don't know if it's like telling me
something you know everyone's online
like that's the way to go I totally get
it because it is like it is like a lot
of work like so many people I know like
just people have like regular jobs have
like nannies and stuff like that because
it's so much work and I used to be like
so against nannies like oh my God people
have news we don't have one right now
but I see why people have it because
it's so much work and it's so exhausting
and so tiring and like my baby hasn't
slept through the night yet so it's just
like so tiring so like I get it and also
it's like you can spoil that baby the
only reason I think I want like I want
more is like because I like having
siblings you know like I just like
having fun yeah like you couldn't have
someone and I always think like you know
when my parents pass away like my older
brother will take care of it I don't
have to take care of it as opposed to
you're the only person you're the only
person left yeah and it's like yeah you
have so much so much attachment to your
parents then yeah right remember we were
having our mama conversation uh in
Montreal one of our friends only has is
an only child yeah and she was saying
she has so much her parents are older
too so her parents are in her their 70s
and she's our age and she so she was
like I feel so much pressure to like I
gotta like create my own family now
because my family will be gone yeah
that's how I feel about that too but I I
know cousin and stuff too I think if
you're close with them yeah do you have
like siblings around here that like have
kids and stuff no I have no one uh are
you an only child I'm so I'm a half I
have a I have a half older sister but so
I think because like for me I've just
realized like it's part of my culture to
just have one because like my dad was an
only child which was very rare for that
time and like I was kind of a half only
child so I think I'm like I think I've
I've locked into this for myself I mean
who knows by the way I could end up
never having kids I could have five kids
like who [__] it's also like dumping
not being attacked it's like puppies
Freedom it's like puppies it's like
one or five you cannot have like
anywhere in between like it's the same
five and one is
cleaning each other and you're like all
right right but you're a two I'm a two
and my that is great we were saying
about nannies earlier
and I accepted it it was a camera
geez nobody thinks you're too
um so I grew up in a country where it is
everyone it doesn't matter like where
you are
um on the ladder everyone is has a nanny
you grow up with a nanny and but what
happened with me was I grew up um my
parents were very rich and so I had
about like six nannies growing up and
then what happened was my parents lost
all their money and then I had I think
from starting the age of eight or nine
the nannies went from six to four to
just one lady and that's when my mom
started beating my ass so it's like as
soon as she lost the help around the
house all of her frustration started to
like bubble over and then the kids paid
for it so it the rule is if you have
nannies keep the nannies until they're
older else the parents will start
beating
do you think he's like overwhelmed or
she was overwhelmed flip it for tick
tock
that's why it's like keep them until
they're 18 and then you can release
um the nannies don't do it in between
because the mom will be like what the
[__] I gotta deal with your ass and just
start beating you but maybe how old were
you how old were you when the nanny
stopped
um right around eight so it went from
six nannies to like one and then it was
occasional it was nannies for two kids
yeah because in the Philippines you have
some a lady that washes your clothes and
you have someone who drives the car you
know you have they call it a Maids
quarter where the nannies live we had
like a little back house wow so um yeah
so you're like five nannies in one as a
person I you thinking about you and
Jules bucketing out the water I want
them to talk they were just bucketing
out the water I'm just like imagining
your school is just like back at home
like back in your Homeland just
bucketing water out of ground
you know what else is helping you just
the two of you it's just the two of us
when she leaves work that's the
shoulders
do you know what is so annoying is when
you go to a doctor's appointment and you
feel like it's all about the doctor like
you waited for them they they rush you
it's all about like they're the center
of attention and they're not really
listening that is why I love ZocDoc
because you can actually find real
patient reviews and find a doctor who
doesn't suck like I went to the doctor
this morning I went to go see an
orthopedic surgeon surgeon I went to go
see an orthopedic surgeon his name is Dr
vaishnav and I'm telling you no greater
like bedside manner everything he took
out the shoulder model everything about
him was 10 out of 10. and that's because
you can look them up on ZocDoc he's
incredible people will tell you he's
incredible yeah and I think it's just
like like when you have to worry about
your health now you have to worry about
whether or not someone is going to be
your ally in this journey it's like it's
it adds just so much more unnecessary
stress it's so like when I had my sinus
infection I had to have Esther diagnose
me doctor I started diagnosed with me
because Dr Esther the doctor I got which
I should have got on ZocDoc was the
worst doctor I've ever had he was so mad
at me he was mad at me I would tell my
something to be like no I'm like I'm
telling you what is happening but can I
just say that's literally normal sorry I
swore but I'm just sleeping we're
keeping it and it's real on that's why
on ZocDoc you will find quality doctors
who actually take the time to listen
they focus on you and your care I it's
2023 I will never go see a doctor ever
again if I have not reviewed them on
ZocDoc well our doctor that we have in
common is an angel and when I first went
in for my physical he was like we should
also do a pap smear he's like but let's
get to know each other first that's the
type of bedside manner ZocDoc will tell
you about okay and ZocDoc is the only
free app that lets you find and book
doctors who are patient reviewed take
your insurance are available when you
need them and treat almost every
condition under the sun no more Dr
roulette or scouring the internet for
questionable reviews with ZocDoc you
have a trusted guide to connect you to
your favorite doctor you haven't met yet
millions of people will use octoc's free
app to find end book a doctor in their
neighborhood who is patient reviewed and
fits their needs and schedule just right
go to zocdoc.com trash and download the
ZocDoc app for free then find and book a
top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours that's
zocdoc.com
trash.com trash and with ZocDoc there
are no alarms and no surprises okay
surprise twists might work when Annie
gives a gift to kalila not when you go
see a doctor this show is sponsored by
betterhelp I don't know about you guys
but I feel like when I'm operating when
I'm operating at my best it's completely
different like I can actually achieve
things I can focus I can like be present
and that is something that I would not
be able to have without a therapist in
my life and it's good to have friends
and family that can help you know
support you when you're having
um issues or trouble coping but it's
another feeling to have an unbiased
highest opinion sort of just guide you a
person who's trained who knows like how
to pick out different patterns and help
you through it because we all have
different like varying levels of anxiety
in the world everyone has a little bit
of something and it manifests in
different ways like you you can't sleep
at night you're spinning all these stuff
if you can just find someone that can
help you figure out what's at the core
of that then it's like you're getting
your sleep you have your tools you're
able to just like go through life and
honestly when you're at your best you
really can do great things yeah and when
I think back to being in my 20s and like
all the things that got in my way of
finding a therapist like just literally
not knowing where to start but simply
with a Google Search and like getting
myself into weird situations therapists
that weren't right for me far drives
like that's why I better help parking
yes yeah no it's just you can't have
more barriers to something like that no
that's why if you are thinking of
therapy better help is a great option
because it makes it simple it's all
online if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit Better Health help.com trash
Tuesday today to get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp help help.com
trash Tuesday
but I I do think that every every mother
should be afforded two nannies when they
first have a child and the government
should pay for it oh that'd be great we
don't get our tampons though yeah yeah
it's never gonna happen well wouldn't
that be great yeah or they also should
give you paid time off like it's crazy
like the people that like have to you
take it like three months off and you
don't get like paid the whole time like
you only get paid like half of it or
something like that's like crazy they
should give you like the first year off
because like your baby will like
literally die if you're like not around
and the fact you just like go back to
work after three months is like insane
to me like leaving my daughter for like
an hour I like feel like she has like
attachment you know like oh something
that's so weird I think they should get
paid time off for like a year I think
any other country does that they like
give like moms like these like huge pay
time off here it's like really weird and
really bad and like they don't pay them
enough it's like crazy because being
it's it's so hard it's so hard and the
nanny thing is interesting like having
two nannies they should like part of the
government or something now uh speaking
of um of newborns you have a newborn on
your finger here oh yeah
wow it's so pretty that is I've been
looking at rings with my boyfriend and
he's like what's who are you competing
with what size you're in I'm like I'm
competing with [__] like Gwen
stefanium oh my gosh I want like the
bigger you know but we ended up finding
my mom found a um an old heirloom that
she didn't know about from my great aunt
that's from the 1800s it's like this
Emerald with all these dogs so we're
getting it like redesigned wait so you
know you're gonna get proposed to oh
yeah but so but yeah but so so my
boyfriend and Whitney are gonna like
plan a like some sort of flash mob or
something to surprise oh my God that's
some sort of something crazy it's a
surprise to not be more opposite that's
like I've I literally have a no flash
mob policy
you also showed up at his hotel room
with like a gun
it wasn't like
or not
bachelor party we were already engaged
but you know but it was
awesome
to do at the bachelor party no I just I
surprised I thought it would be like a
fun surprise the girl who hates
surprises loves to do that
knocking on the door his hotel room when
he's trying to hang out with his boys it
did not go was he with like a hooker or
something no he had some fun she would
have liked it right he was literally
watching the news
um but oh you guys are soul mates I know
yeah it did it did not go well but we I
okay question are you getting married
because you've been engaged longer than
me you've been engaged for like I know
we're all gonna get married before
forever yeah that happened I mean at
this rate I'm gonna get married but
first I don't even have anybody I have a
Christmas present for kalila but it's in
my car and so I don't know if I should
get it now or during banana break should
I do it at Banana break yes I think I
still do those I love it that's
everything yes I thought that was like
just like a one-time thing but then I
watch your show and I'm like oh they
always do like bananas and everyone's
like mad at us for it but we can't oh
they don't miss the phonic people yeah I
love it Trisha we've seen you do so much
musicals you know becoming different
fast food fast casual employees
what can you tell us about what you want
for this year what's coming down the
pipeline what's inspiring you what are
we going to see my gosh okay so I play
like the Mega Millions every Tuesday and
Friday it's over a billion dollars right
now it's like 1.3 billion I always play
it I get 20 worth like every Tuesday
Friday like I swear I'm gonna win it
like I see it in my head so if I won the
Mega Millions and get the billion
dollars I would go to India and I really
want to make like a Bollywood film like
I really about like my me and Moses like
love story and like really do like the
whole thing like I really really I like
that you wanted to be a billion dollar
budget
really Grand I want to go to India I
want to do it because I always like saw
myself adopting kids from India too so
maybe I'll do that yeah yeah I like
learning dances
I had like a social media team who um
behind my back bought all these like
really cheap ads and so then I all of a
sudden had all these like Indian like
everything was Indian oh yeah because
and but it was like at midnight in India
it was like the weirdest thing I was
like why is everyone ending where was
this at where was this on it was no my
my social media team I had to fire them
because I was like did you do something
like no we didn't do anything and then
all of a sudden it was like all my reach
was in India all of a sudden so then I
learned like Bollywood dances and stuff
on my solo podcast they might buy them
too because I had someone do that on my
Facebook like monetize it and then all
of a sudden like oh everyone from India
was like watching my video so I don't
know if they like bought them or they
just get like yeah I was like I don't
want that I want real yeah
I love in Indianapolis
um we have a producer he's like uh how
would you describe George he's like kind
of this nerdy yeah
he had Bollywood dreams too wow so he
grew up George and Bali yes he moved to
India to become a Bollywood director
what what you guys all know this so he
grew up
he grew up um um in the religious he had
a religious upbringing and they were not
allowed a lot of things which was
dancing no caffeine no um eating meat
nothing yeah so when he was finally when
he turned 18 I think like he lined up
cocaine and like all like and he was
like I'm gonna move to India and be a
Bollywood director and he lived there
for a couple years did he do anything
did he do any like I think at most he
was a PA on us
wait a second Georges have failed
Bollywood oh he is yeah there's a lot he
does seem like he has a dream that
hasn't been realized he's fighting
something I thought maybe he was in the
closet but it's not is the Bollywood I
will totally hire him as the Director
because I don't have a director in mind
I have actors in mine but I don't have a
good director fulfill each other's
dreams and he knows all of the big like
Indian he knows them by like first lap
middle last name I want to dress her
like George like if we had this wig but
it was like had a mullet like and then
put George's glasses
I'll do it I like I'll cosplay anybody
that means that really is so fun it's so
cute yeah I love it oh my God that's so
crazy wow maybe that's meant to be that
oh my gosh who's that oh that's him
that's George oh I did you you met him
yeah yeah okay I was like he looks so
familiar did he have a baby he just had
a second baby a girl and he and he says
it's like night and day from when he had
his first oh it's the feeling of having
the kid no the baby she's just dreamy
sleeps and you know it's just softer and
much easier how do you guys feel about
like the parenting style likes what
George had were I guess that's like a
religion I don't know we're like you're
not allowed to have
anything fun I'll tell you what happens
wait what he went to Colombia and got
like basically date raped and robbed
that's what happens if you restrict the
child too much they're gonna up and
leave to Colombia and get a bigger
they're gonna sniff that virgin out
let me take this guy's virginity again
like I grew up with no religion and no
rules so that's all I know but I do feel
like it made me not like when I got to
college I didn't try drugs I didn't try
alcohol because I was just like I it
there wasn't that like restraint or it
wasn't like you didn't you feel like it
wasn't naughty yeah it wasn't bad yeah
so I'm just like it does I wonder like
what is the right level though because
I'm definitely not okay but like you're
okay but you're good you know you're not
like dead in a ditch you know yeah which
is like totally because I think I Mine
mine's kind of like the opposite like I
kind of grew up like I wouldn't say like
strict we weren't like you know like you
know what but my dad was like super
religious like Catholic all this stuff
like that so like it was very much like
have sex until you're married don't live
with someone January like that kind of
stuff so then like yeah when I turn like
I mean I was like under 18 like 17 when
I came to La like I literally I was just
like Full Throttle like having sex with
everyone I could like try any drug I
could because I was like well this is
like what people do and like you know I
thought it was like fun and no one told
me like I was never told like how you
get pregnant how to give a [__] like
none of this stuff yeah so like in our
school we were taught abstinence and we
weren't taught like condoms so like I've
never this is like so embarrassing but
what and it's so embarrassing it's
whatever I never like wear a condom with
anyone because like I didn't even like
no I didn't know what they were like it
just seemed like something that like I
did not want in my body well if it makes
you say wearing a condom like you think
you have to put it yeah right you put it
in and then they put their dick in it if
it makes you feel better I grew up with
a like very Jewish liberal education and
I definitely learned about condoms and I
also did not use them yeah okay
we're not a real condom can you can you
tell Trish about the time when you were
like you told a boy that no we don't
need to wear a condom and he still
insisted yes oh the first time I had sex
with the guy it was on our third day and
I was like no we don't need a car I was
like oh no we don't need a condom and
he's like no we should use one and now
he's gonna be my husband
really did you wake up in a puddle of
what was that who you bled for no that
was a different guy where I woke up with
my period And I was like I can't tell
you how many times they're like you're
so wet I'm like yeah I'm pretty wet oh
my God I had people get mad at me they
get like so pissed like why are you on
my period I'm like I did it just started
like you know I stopped it
out but that really is a thing you can't
plunge it out I think but I do think it
helps like when you have like heavy flow
it does help to get a dick and down I
think so too you get the big quads yeah
but you gotta do it in the shower if I'm
having a big crampy day yeah I go to the
shower and I ask my partner will you
please plunge me no way he gets the
clots just come out I feel better [__]
big
um cherries and apples in there I mean
of course I have it all but I have a lot
of sex on my period is very difficult
for me like that is I'm just I'm just
surrender to it I don't want anyone in
the same room with me when I'm like okay
because is that why you feel really ill
you you guys have like you enjoy period
Well I have so much anxiety about
getting pregnant because Todd's like my
person and my guy and who I know we have
Frozen embryos but I just like don't
want to get pregnant yet because I'm
just having so much fun on the road you
know and so I have so much anxiety that
I know my like least least chance of me
getting pregnant is when I'm on my
period I think I just I'm super horny on
my period I get like that too and I do
that yeah yeah because you work on a wet
you're like okay no totally and you just
want to like do it I mean I kind of
agree with you where I'm kind of like it
is like I don't know I don't like love
it but I do get so horny on it where I'm
like okay well I don't want to like
stick a toy in there so I just like
let's put the showers again the shower
is a good alternative because I don't
like it on the bed like with a towel
like it's just a little sticky and like
gross wet yeah I mean I need a nanny to
do the laundry I need a nanny and then I
need one Nanny to take my period
well like I where you Jewish now know or
just race Jewish I was basically raised
like kind of half like barely religious
Jew like I went to Jewish preschool and
like culturally we did all the things
but I didn't my dad was not religious so
we didn't do the religious and you're
not practicing now no because like
Jewish and like in Judaism like you're
not even supposed to sleep in the same
room as your wife when she's on her
period like you're sleeping like
separate beds for like isn't that
Orthodox
I feel like that's like super strict
Orthodox right I see it on my Tick Tock
again I'm on like this like weird like
Jewish Tick Tock now where it's like
always talking about like when you can
have sex and like and you can't use
protection when you're like Jewish
because it's like you know trying to
like interfere with God's plan like it's
really interesting well I like that so
when you're on your period like you're
the meat and they're the milk and it has
to be like
it's interesting interesting I was like
wow that's so interesting and I think
it's like two weeks they can't sleep
with each other how is Judaism going for
you I didn't finish conversion I really
did try I did try Europe school dropout
I literally have a shirt that says that
there's a song do you know the no effect
song the bruise it's a really good Jew
song you should listen to it I'm like a
quarter every time I every time I do 23
may I get more Jewish it's like so weird
I'm like 23 I mean what are you [__]
up to what's going on here everyone's a
little Jewish and um wait that would be
cool if it was like run by Jewish people
and they're just trying to slowly turn
I've been no honestly I've been doing a
joke about that where I'm like Kanye I
don't know if you're right about
Hollywood but I think 23 amazing they
are recruiting Me Slowly well like
initially like when the first time I got
23 in me this was like 10 years ago
there was like two three percent that
was unassigned
um and they kind of don't know what that
two three percent is but maybe that's I
think the more people that match your
DNA come together yeah they use that
information to like grow that right but
yeah we're like 22 Ashkenazi
wow interesting I see it yeah well she's
not a good night
I think everyone is Jewish like if you
think about it like everyone kind of
stemmed from
Abraham I don't know everyone was been
watching it anybody been watching apron
oh I live for Abraham I guess they're
like daily reminders so good yeah
abrahamics is the like the first uh
non-binary yeah
so you know what Abraham mixes okay can
you explain this to me I think I
understand it it's Esther Hicks and her
husband yeah and her husband's dead
though right he passed away right I
don't know but Abraham Hicks is like an
idea an entity it's like she's like
being made up and it's not just one
person it's like a it's like the beings
they like talk to her and she channels
her and it sounds so crazy but it's like
all of the work that I've done like if I
watched these videos before I did Jim
Thorton's podcast stuff before I did
hypnosis all this stuff I would be like
this makes no sense I am in this [__]
ballist State listening to them now it
makes so much sense it's just all about
like leaning towards like the light of
your life and just like the happiness
and that you're on the earth to have joy
it's just so it's such a relief I was
hooked I like read like the first like
10 pages of it and it literally is like
her talking about how I was like for 15
minutes she had like this orgasmic
feeling like come over here where she's
like oh it's just like peace and like
the answer is like come to you later and
I do that every morning like when I was
pregnant I meditated for literally two
hours every morning now I do like 15
minutes you really were like such a
pregnancy icon because I feel like so
many people in the spotlight when they
get pregnant are like I just want to
like normalize how horrible this is yeah
everyone everyone's like showing you
their barf bucket and [__] yeah okay
Alaska ceremony and it's like I think
that's great show your truth or whatever
but it's like it is like as when we're
cuspies like when we're like are we
gonna do this or not all of us it's nice
to have you're so happily pregnant I
loved it it was like the happy like I
just want to like get pregnant again to
be pregnant like because the labor and
delivery is kind of like awful I mean
still not as bad as like people say like
I was scared I literally thought it was
because she got a good [__] did they
cut you yeah no I what wait what up are
this when they cut the the did you have
a oh no I had a C-section yeah I didn't
like choose it I actually like tried to
push for like three hours because I
thought this I love watching like birth
Vlogs like people like pushing it comes
out there's something like so like I
don't know animalistic about it I like
really wanted it but it didn't work out
for me I was really sad but but I will
say like C-section and I don't want
people to come for me for me it was like
it's like so easy I was pushing for
three hours I was like dying they put an
oxygen mask on me the C-section it was
done in like 10 minutes and the baby's
out I'm like well we should just started
with that you know what I mean just
taking it out of me and it was like so
the recovery is like a little bit sucky
but I'm sure like a vaginal one would be
really something no okay so speaking of
Abraham Hicks and what you just said
where you were saying I don't want
people to come for me I just listened to
an Abraham Hicks yesterday that was
about performers and stuff and it was
she was saying like if you're attached
to like the reaction of the audience
that's not really what the vibration is
what your job is as like a performer is
that you are giving off your vibrations
and when they match and help people
align with their vibrations those are
the people that you're there for and the
other ones just aren't they just didn't
match they didn't align so that's what
everything but that's true with
everything like frequency like if we're
like we're all on the same frequency and
like but like you feels good if it
doesn't feel if it's feels bad then
you're not just thinking about that
level I'm all about that too I like
never meditate I thought I was like all
[__] and I'm like all about it it's
so fun and I do feel like I feel like
answers I like just come to you
sometimes like you just sit in silence
for like a half hour and like all of a
sudden like throughout like a couple
days later like oh that's the answer to
this yeah I've been doing breath work
too do you ever do breath work oh all
the time because I'm like borderline so
I do like DBT classes which is all about
like breathing your surprises and stuff
like that which is like kind of the same
thing it's all kind of the same like
medicine I love it I love doing that
stuff and it really helped me yeah get
myself under did you have like I'm
noticing this is something that women
are talking about more which is like the
fourth trimester which is like the three
months after you give birth that are
actually some people say are much harder
than the pregnancy did you experience
that yeah for sure it is kind of weird
because I never thought I like had like
postpartum depression because like I
feel pretty good but they're they're
definitely it definitely your hormones
do get out of whack there are times like
I would just like cry like a month after
my daughter was born My Chemical Romance
was in town and I had tickets for all
five nights and I wanted to go so bad
and every night I was like I really want
to go I really want to go but I just was
like no I need to stay home like I feel
so guilty and I just ended up not going
to any of the five nights and like the
last night I just like bawled my eyes I
like locked myself in the bathroom for
literally like five hours I slept on the
couch at night like I was so I was like
pissed at my husband for some reason I
don't know and he's like if you want to
go you should go like go with your
sister and I was like No And I just I
just I was like so upset I'm like why am
I so upset over this like I wanted my
daughter my whole life and I'm like so
mad that I can't go see like My Chemical
Romance so it's like stuff like that
happens and it's really scary because I
was like shoot like what's wrong with me
and just other things like sometimes
you're like oh my God like I had a baby
like this is for life like there's like
I'm there's no turning back like that
can like also like kind of like mess
with you for a little bit but
um I think that's like relatively normal
when I talk to people about it like
everyone else kind of feels that same
way I was like I don't really know what
I'm doing and also like this is like the
rest of my life like I can't like go
yeah there's like moments like that but
it's it's being far between thank you
for sharing that I really like hearing
stuff like that because it's like I I
feel like at least I want to anticipate
those kinds of feelings so that when
they do if they ever do hit I'm not and
foreign
yeah like it's so weird how little
people know about postpartum depression
question like I can't remember if I've
talked about this here but my Dad
recently was like postpartum depression
is that where they try to kill the baby
and I'm like oh my God we do not know
like we're just it's just not talked
about enough yeah but stuff like that
does happen where people do like have
like violent thoughts about that like
stuff like that it's like actually like
as I looked really into it I was like
you know is what I have you know just me
being sad about my camera romance
depression compared to it's different
levels because some people are and some
people need to like be separated from
the baby and so like it can be like
scary for sure but it really is like a
hormonal thing like it's not really like
your thoughts it's not like real yeah
yeah like your hormones are so out of
whack and it's like birth like birth is
like trauma like it's like you go
through like this trauma of like trying
to push this baby out and you're like
worried it's gonna go wrong like it's a
lot like and I was on a lot of
medications like a lot of drugs and I
got the C-section they gave me like the
Fentanyl and stuff like that and I was
like out of my mind and I remember when
she came I like didn't know where she
was I mean obviously my husband was
there the whole time but like I didn't
know where she was and it was or like
what was happening it was it was yeah
when you get a C-section do they just
like show you the baby right because
they have to like do surgery yeah to
really like bond with it no I know I
didn't get any skin to skin at all it
was literally like they took her out my
husband got the like umbilical cord and
then like washed her off they like put
her in your face like kiss the baby and
then they like take it away and that's
it like it was really like crazy and
then you're in the hospital for a few
days but again I was like I was on some
medications when I went home from the
hospital I chose not to take any like
pain medication because I just I hated
being out of it so much like I was so
confused what was happening and it was
it was like crazy but
um but like like I'm really I thought I
would be worse honestly I thought I'd be
more like depressed because like when my
when we started living together me and
Moses like I would wake up every morning
and be oh my God there's someone next to
me and I was like worried that was gonna
happen with a baby like oh my God I have
a baby but I don't really like feel that
way as much it's more like but with
Moses I really was just like oh my God
there's someone like lip like when we
got married I was like oh my God he's
next to me every morning it was like
weird I have like that weird adjustment
yeah but yeah but baby is like the best
decision I like I want more it's
interesting that your dad said oh isn't
that when like women like kill their
babies
um what I learned in nursing school is
that when
um young kids or young babies come in
for like head trauma most of the time
they call it like shaken baby syndrome
like 99 of the time it's from the dad
and and I'm like you know a lot of times
it's like I think just like as a mother
like you just you know how like the
likelihood of you rolling over your dog
if you're a woman is like really low but
a likelihood of a dude rolling over your
dog same with a baby I think that you're
just sort of like primed more to like
hear Christ you know like kind of react
there would be a it would be a problem I
think about that a lot like with the
that how women have so much more
intuition and attention to detail
because Dave my partner he's very smart
like he is smarter than me whatever like
that's fine but I've noticed and this
I've learned it through him it's like my
ability to remember details pay
attention to details is so much more in
tune in advance than his and I'm like oh
it's literally like that's just a skill
that women have that men don't have
right same like even I I call them the
tippy tappies of my dogs if somebody
needs to pee in the middle of the night
they don't need to whine or bark I can
hear their tippy tappies and Bobby would
if they were barking whining like
scratching at his face he still wouldn't
wake up yeah but the tiniest little like
tip tip tip I'm awake and I'm like okay
let me take you out and I think that
just women are a little bit better in
that way I do feel like uh like a Nate
nurturing thing you know like even the
other day when you put my stuff up on
the on the stool when we're at The
Comedy Store it's like yeah those little
things you just like notice little
things that yeah that's like coming up
for me more in my 30s I'm like I want to
care for yeah yeah so it's because I
think with our options right of like not
we cannot have kids and still live these
like rock star Lifestyles and do all
this stuff but it I think you have to
find out where to put your energy
because I think you just naturally are
supposed to at a certain age be focusing
on something else like just as our
bodies are like made and stuff so it's
like what do you do with that because if
it's just going on to yourself you're
gonna go [__] crazy yeah it's
interesting because like I was at that
level too I was like 33 when I got
pregnant and it's kind of one of those
like stages where I just feel like oh my
I mean you can have kids in your 40s
obviously too but like it was one of
those stages where it's like okay like
now or never like I'm gonna have kids or
I'm not gonna have kids but it's like
also you don't know if you're gonna be a
good mom until you have a kid and then
like it's kind of like again too late so
if you're like wait I'm not good at this
like you kind of but I will say like
what you're saying in the maternal
Instinct kind of kicks in because I
don't I'd never consider myself maternal
or like nurturing before I was like
really selfish and so when I did have a
baby it does kind of like just kick in
that like you know how to take care like
I just know you just like knew how to
take care of her like you know when
she's hungry you know what her cries are
for which is like something I never felt
with like any baby or anything or even
dogs like I was very just like not good
at like taking care of anything I never
took care of anything and it's actually
that's so sweet because like you're
molecularly entangled yeah like you're
just connected your oxytocin is
completely related to The Cry yeah
that's it's so true they say like the
cuddles like alone like and it really
does like when I was feeling like you
know my bouts of depression or I feel
really sad like literally like cuddling
with a baby like like increases all
those levels it's like crazy it's like
really yeah it feels really natural and
it is an extension I mean for the first
month the baby thinks it's like still a
part of you it's like really crazy so
that's why like you can't be apart from
it okay I still think she's a part of
her parents I am that's because I am
only child syndrome maybe a two-person
question but just want to ask in case
but you don't have to answer like sex
life after baby
is like is I hear that like it's really
hard and then sometimes it's like people
don't have a problem problem is is there
anything you can share on that so
interesting yeah and again I never want
to like describe to anyone else's
Journey because like my pregnancy is so
easy and like honestly I like wanted to
have sex like right away it was actually
so weird like I was so horny but you
bleed you bleed and this is something I
didn't know maybe a lot of people know
this but like you bleed for like six
weeks after like just constantly like I
wore a diaper for six weeks after you're
just like constantly bleeding I started
a dream
the bathtub yeah it's literally that so
like the only thing that was like really
stopping us was that like I was like
bleeding um but I was like really really
horny but but I also didn't have vaginal
so like I didn't like it didn't hurt you
know what I mean so I think I think that
would make like such a bit because you
have stitches down there it's like to me
that's why so I had this the C-section
but I have like a um like lipo and stuff
before and to me it was kind of like the
same recovery thing for that but we had
sex like within like three weeks I mean
we were like okay because they say
you're also really fertile and of course
we want another baby and my husband's
like in his 40s so we're like let's try
for baby number two right away so we've
been trying but no luck yeah but
hopefully soon but like they say You're
really fertile yeah they're like because
I never thought I was gonna get pregnant
I was like infertile for like so long
and we did this one test called hsg test
where they like clear your tubes out and
we got pregnant like right after that
interesting yeah because I like couldn't
get pregnant even with my husband not
like we couldn't have pregnant for like
a year and a half so it was crazy it
seems to be that has got pregnant so
maybe we'll do that again I don't know
yeah
um one of my good friends she has four
kids now but she said that um the doctor
was like well listen to your body when
it's time to have sex again you know we
always say six weeks but just listen to
your body you know when you know and
she's like I had my husband like just
pop those stitches at two weeks I was
like I was so [__] horny I listened
to my body she's like I couldn't do it I
was willing to just give any like risk
anything that get [__] that's kind of
how I felt too because you're like it's
like a de-stressor like I don't know sex
to me is like very like it's like
something to distress and it's like you
can't really do much anyways when you
have a newborn so it's kind of like
that's kind of the thing I loved it I
mean I still do and it's just I don't
know you just feel like more more like
sexy I don't know and I feel like it's
probably harder to have sex when the
kids are more like
they need you more as far as like
walking around and you need to be like
really watching yeah for sure like the
cages are forced they do have those oh
my gosh I put you in a cage because they
were just banging so much that's my
culture oh no
that's good that's good it's a good
thing you know what your brain's not
banging I just don't want to know about
it yes you do
so you do Esther you do
I'm so excited that we're working with
green Chef because I love their food it
tastes so good green Chef is the number
one meal kit for eating well with
dinners that work for you not the other
way around green Chef has options for
every lifestyle keto paleo vegan
vegetarian fast and fit Mediterranean
Mediterranean and gluten-free as the
only keto meal kit green Chef makes
sticking to carb conscious lifestyle
easy it's so easy to have something
delicious you don't have to sacrifice
taste they're great you're not like
going to the store having to find all
these stuff it's just like really easy
but like literally listen it's green
chefs pre-made and pre-measured sauces
dressings and spices they make keeping a
healthy lifestyle even easier and like
taste good and you don't have to stress
and worry about it put the time you save
on meal prep towards actually achieving
your 2023 goals and what I love is that
green Chef is the only meal kit that is
both carbon and plastic off set we they
offset 100 of their carbon footprint as
well as a hundred percent of the plastic
in every box and they feature organic
produce premium proteins and sustainably
sourced ingredients I love sometimes
I'll get the vegan meals and then
sometimes I'll do the keto like I'm you
know not religiously attached to one but
I love switching it up and also they
have Mediterranean I just like that you
can try different Lifestyles and like
see what you're feeling that week you
know it's completely customizable it's
just great it's so hard like when you go
on one of these types of diets too where
it's you have to like check all the
ingredients and stuff it's so hard you
can't go out to eat really it's so hard
to do it you know there's gonna be
something hidden and stuff if you're
doing keto you have to be in ketosis so
it is really important to make sure
everything's measured out and this does
it for you it's like come on and it's
delicious I feel really good about it
too because a hundred percent of their
Seafood meets the Monterey Bay Aquarium
Seafood watch rankings of certified Best
Choice or good alternative
I keep that little booklet
yeah no I know it because like Monterey
Bay is like they're the top tier
go to greenchef.com trash tuesday60 and
use code trash tuesday60 to get 60 off
plus free shipping that's greenchef.com
trash tuesday60 and use code trash
tuesday60 to get 60 off plus free
shipping green Chef the number one meal
kit for eating well green Chef is now
owned by hellofresh and with a wider
array of meal plans to choose from
there's something for everyone I love
switching between the brands and now our
listeners can do the same
we're so like baby starved this is crazy
I'm just curious and she's like been
such a public like I feel like you're
like the public-facing millennial right
before we got pregnant too yeah yeah
that's crazy it's so long ago yeah and
you came to my wedding I love so sad I
missed your wedding no I know I knew you
guys were busy
I was shocked to see you actually
because you know like always you're like
you know you don't expect anyone to come
to the wedding so when I saw you I was
so excited oh my gosh you look so great
you're the only one in color I know I
felt so bad I had to live where we had a
dress code of like wearing all white and
as her Halloween the bright turquoise
thing and you look beautiful though it
was like everything she like read it
wrong I loved it I loved it seriously I
loved it because you like stuck like I
saw you like I could see you like in the
crowd I needed to stand out yeah no you
were great what inspired that because
that was so unique and special you
actually like gave me some dare I say my
own wedding motivation because like you
created this like unique experience
where like she said everyone was
supposed to wear white not me but
um and you came out in this beautiful
black amazing gorgeous wedding gown like
what inspired that well I mean I
Christine Quinn got married the year
before and she had a black one so I
really was inspired by that but like she
had she didn't really have the dress
code the reason dress code came around
was because like our wedding ended up
being a disaster because like we spent
so much and we it looked like really
cheap like we had no lighting it was
like it was crazy we got we got scammed
all over the place for our wedding like
literally like two weeks for our wedding
nothing was a book except for the venue
so like we had to like pull like Louie
they spent all our savings trying to get
like entertainment and like some sort of
like things because I don't know where
all the money went like we got we
definitely got a little scammed I'm not
gonna lie so it was like very
frustrating so we didn't have like any
props any flowers if you notice there
was like no flowers in our wedding even
though our wedding was crazy expensive
and it looks like like literally twenty
thousand dollars but we like got scammed
out of like hundreds of thousands of
dollars no flowers is kind of iconic
though oh it was not iconic they don't
need a [__] flower we put like
candles from our own home down like the
aisle it was like literally that and so
we thought well if we have like our
guests we're all white like they kind of
like become like part of the decoration
so like when you watch like the crowd
you see like all this like sea of like
white and everyone looks like really
pretty and so that one Esther I live for
it I live for it I really did I thought
that was everything what color did you
wear it was a turquoise coat I think I
had white on underneath the coat and it
was cold maybe it's always cold
by yourself right I did I thought you
were like fiance was gonna come with you
no I know I forgot where I think he had
something weird that night and I was
like I'm gonna go by myself we're so
bummed because we were like really
looking at like furry white jackets and
stuff like we were gonna really go I
love going I love going to things by
myself like I just and I met such great
people at the table Yeah they have to
like learn to love it no
[Laughter]
that's something I can't do I cannot go
to places alone I cannot like go to
restaurants by myself movies really I
don't even like going like like again
Moses used to come with me everywhere
like you drive me around stuff like even
now it's like scary to go anywhere by
myself like to go to like through a fast
food by myself I like don't like it at
all until I go to a wedding by myself
I'd be like I was you're like I have the
confidence I told you this to text you
like your confidence is like so insane
you just like don't give a [__] about
anything and I love that I love
everything about it I follow you for hot
girl tips but you're like the hot girl
of my heart oh my God I love you I love
you I really do I got so excited when
you texted me I was like oh my God oh my
God where's soulmate but I know I try
not to be a girl too hard
oh my God like no ask Carlos I was like
oh my gosh I was dying when you showed
up and reboot because that was like my
show I like lived for that show and I
didn't know you were gonna be on it and
I was like okay I wish I would they
stopped that halfway I love that show I
I feel like they might have more I'm not
sure
it's a show on Hulu with Rachel Bloom
it's really good I feel like it's really
good actually so good and Nikki's cast
yeah I love it I love what's this Keegan
Michael yeah I like that Esther does pop
up Esther pops up it's crazy if you look
at any TV show from like the past like
13 years there's like always like a
little Esther Cameo playing an 18 year
old like above age 18 to look younger
that was my sweet spot for her that's
how I feel about Sophie's um boyfriend
Scoops yeah scoots and everything scoots
and everything we have a friend
um soci bacon and her her boyfriend I
mean I now we have a running joke in the
house where it's like oh scoots in it
scoots in it scoots in everything
everything oh yeah oh wow
yeah he's that person like you wouldn't
know his name but you see his face they
match really well together too yeah what
to who's his is his girlfriend someone
like an actor she was in that um smile
she was the leader is it a horror movie
yeah I feel like I've seen that like oh
wow yeah they're they have the it couple
cute I love her dad my dad's Kevin oh
for Papa I wonder if that gets annoying
like because everyone's like your dad's
gonna get excited you know that her
dad's kind of baking like or does she
like love it I've always wanted that
I've always wondered like annoyed by it
never she never seems annoyed she loves
her family they're like a really close
family because then you see people like
like Bono's son like never like be
associated with his dad like I'm like
why don't you want to because he has his
own band and stuff I'm like why wouldn't
you want to say you know well the iconic
um Billy Bob Thornton thing where he got
mad when they were he was like doing
some of this band and they kept wanting
to talked about the movies that he was
doing and he like didn't want to do it
but it's like I feel like you should be
proud of all the things you're doing and
yeah we'll get to all of your that whole
thing right now nepo babies everyone's
like pissed about Napa babies I'm like
it's just so crazy like why do people
care that much like why do they care
like you have to be like talented to
like be on stranger things like like Uma
Thurman's daughter I'm like you know
Chef is like a good actor and you're
hanging out with good actors all the
time too yeah so you're like but also
the idea that if my father was a
mechanic and I was around mechanics and
then I myself become a mechanic because
I love cars yeah is like am I a mechanic
nepo baby yeah literally it's like it's
just kind of what you're immersed in I
just watched um made the like short
series on Netflix with um with uh Andy
McDowell's daughter in it and she's such
a good actress it's like oh yeah you
can't like fake being a good actor like
she was just like really good there are
some nepo babies where I'm like okay
like acting could use you know some work
there I think the problem like the con
that's what seems to be like the theme
of the conversation is like when people
are nepo baby and they're like that
didn't help me I think like that's what
pisses people off especially I think in
a modeling world yeah right not so much
in acting because you really have to
kind of prove your worth in acting
because people can obviously see whether
or not you're talented but in modeling
like Kendall Jenner saying like or who
was it who was like you know like I
really did work so hard and of course
you work so hard but you had the leg up
yeah yeah yeah also working hard okay
but it's never but no I'm proud of all
of you but it's I also agree with you
you guys it's like that is it's cool I
mean we all like it like we like seeing
someone and finding out oh my God
they're that person's kid like it's fun
when you watch very fun you see the um
they had a it was a short-lived TV show
I think I don't think I got a second
season I only saw a couple episodes but
it was a good it was a fun idea it was
like a bunch of nepo babies put in a
house and it was hosted by like the
other
Jonas brother and it's like they're all
siblings or nieces or cousins or
Daughters of famous people
what a fun yes it was so good but it
wasn't fair because they had like Dean
Martin's granddaughter I'm like who's
gonna know that because you gotta like
basically guess who they were related to
which is like so crazy because some of
these people were to celebrate we all
have known each other right like didn't
they don't nepo babies know each other
but then I was like were they not put
babies like Brett Favre's daughter like
like who wouldn't know you know and then
but of course in like Laverne Cox's twin
brother of course you're gonna know that
it's like it wasn't so fair yeah maybe
they knew or maybe they gave him like
hints or something like that like Kiki
Palmer sister was on there and it was
just like I don't know it was an
interesting I love that show though I
was like so about it because I do like I
love the like who looks like who and
what like when you meet someone's baby
or someone's kid or someone's parents
like I love seeing like the combination
of the parents I love when nepo babies
turn into Chet Hanks and who's that
others when they go they go away yeah
yeah I mean but I love that kind of
rebellion and above the other one shot
hangs it's so funny
I think they are yeah whoa I thought it
was like it's wild you have one there's
usually one rapper in the bloodline
banana break
shall we
wait but who is whose daughter is a
daughter of a really big director who
became a porn girl
oh I don't know I think it's not it's
not Steven Spielberg it's somebody else
Bobby told me this recently but they try
to like keep it on the hush he's a
famous director famous director's
daughter like a huge I also have like a
nepo baby I just found she's a model
she's not that successful at it but
she's like really pretty
um Jake Ryan from Sixteen Candles
daughter
remember he quick he like quit right he
did I was just like where is he now and
they're like his daughter's a model but
he um he married a model and then had
kids and then quit acting did you watch
Sixteen Candles was that one of the two
movies you saw it's Steven Spielberg's
Daughter by the way oh my God what my
alma mater which state Michaela
wow wow
stevensburg what oh my God that's that
I'll be right back from 2020
is a healing Journey that's so
interesting so she thought doing porn
was
wow that's awesome before I leave can I
just say
um
wait this is my gift hour I'm going to
get you a gift I got Now esther
is known to call me out on my ridiculous
spending oh no this is one where I can
say this was a wild purchase Oh my God
this was very impulsive I will get it
now I saw it I don't think anyone really
owns one I might be the only one that
actually bought one it was 360. oh my
God don't feel pressure to do I already
told you when you are given a gift you
can throw in the dumpster it's fine it's
already been done I thought at one point
it had been stolen by a homeless person
and I was like this is actually the
funniest thing for someone to steal but
it did come in the mail yesterday I'm so
excited I'll be right back
oh my God oh my God it's a man-sized
teddy bear to spoon at night when you're
lonely any that rolls
do not touch my lover
there's only one rule when you're on
your period it has to be in another room
for the weight is really good hang on
let me roll with him no you could really
spoon it straddle it where did you find
that it was like I think like a gag
thing that was like I saw in a meme and
I bought it I'm the [__] that buys the
meme thing I love them
wow no I got a sick boy
oh my God that's a boy is that a girl
get up
on a ties isn't it so good
that's the greatest gift imagine a
homeless person stole that and was like
just on the street sure it wasn't it
didn't spend a night with a home I
promise it did not we got the box
yesterday Todd and I were laughing
Todd's like it's on my on my solo
podcast anniewood we have a segment
called uh the thing segment because I
just always buy things and this is my
most probably my name
can I typically I'm not really into
dudes with small heads
you know I like big-headed dudes but I
love I love a tubby tubby he's so
[__] hot like yeah
long legged look at the calves you know
I don't like chicken legs oh my God
Annie you know wait I could put like um
I can make this um a little bit stiffer
and use it oh my God I should have
gotten you the rubber fist to like put
in it oh he's so you could just swap the
heads if you want a bigger head to swap
it out I was like you [__] bought
that I was like yes I like to spoil my
girls
this is thank you so much this means so
much to me
oh no maybe you can get his shoulders I
heard that bone on bone oh my gosh
that's so cool thank you Annie you're
welcome I don't know why he's so sad
you're gonna lift his eyelids up was he
like five ten I think he's a little
taller I think he's taller than me
I love it it's so cute another question
I love it we're so happy for you
I knew I was going to set you up with
someone I have a podcast coming out soon
um yeah I have two actually but I can't
talk about them until like February
they're two separate ones totally
different with two different like
companies and two totally different
people
um ones with the guy one's with a girl
and so like I haven't done podcast
that's why I came to do this because I
haven't done podcasts in so long so I've
been trying to like get back out there
doing like podcasts and stuff like that
because
um I just like don't know if I'm like
good at it because I like literally oh
my gosh
pregnant I like didn't see anyone and I
was like can I even talk to people
anymore like it's really you know it's
scary so that's like let me come try
this again I'm hard knock yesterday but
today has a has a glisten to it
yeah I don't know that is something you
will never lose that's just innately
just you're just good at it I hope I
don't know and that's why I like have
don't do much anymore like I used to
have like all this like controversy and
like I don't really just do anything I
don't like say anything I don't even
keep up like genuinely I don't keep up
with like anything that's out there so
like if people are like oh she's gonna
get riled about this I see it all the
time like are you gonna respond I have
no idea what anyone's talking about I
don't even like go to like indulge in it
because I'm like I don't even know yeah
I just got so tired of everything I
don't know and like again I brought on
like all the drama myself so I was just
like so tired it was like so exhausting
so I was just like you know just like I
don't really go on like I just go on
Tick Tock and that's it and there's like
no drama about me and if there is I like
scroll as soon as I see something I'm
like scroll but that's great yeah yeah
but there's nothing really going on I
don't think I don't know maybe there is
but for me I'm like I don't think
there's anything going on yeah I feel
like since doing this podcast I've
really arrived at this place of like
people are I think we even talked about
this yesterday it's like people are
gonna
some people are going to hate you some
people are going to love you might as
well just do you yeah because no matter
what you do they're they're not gonna
like it or they're gonna like it so true
like last year I didn't like talk about
anyone anything I disengaged from
everything and they still found like
waist like hate on me it was like so
crazy and I was like okay that's why I
had to like stop reading because I'm
like I'm literally doing nothing I'm
getting hate so but kalila came up with
a you were saying like maybe like three
or four episodes ago where you were like
I'm just like you're like surrendering
to the fact that you're just like a an
online celebrity right yeah
um like whatever it is they need me to
be to um exist in the compartment in
their mind I cannot like contend without
or compete with that so whatever it is
that I am to you as an audience member
is I accept it yeah all I truly care
about for myself is who I am to my
mother my family my friends my
co-workers and those are the things that
I can control and my new boyfriend who I
will treat with so much but I sent you
the from The Velveteen Rabbit because I
had forgotten about that and I texted
Esther at like 2 A.M yesterday and you
forget like all of these gems that you
know you read when you're younger and
you're like wait like now it it lands a
little bit different differently
and the quote is once you are real you
can't be ugly except to people who don't
understand
and I don't know that just I'm like that
just releases you of like so much you
know yeah it's also it's just like there
it's so much about them I've had so many
times in my life more so recently
because I think I'm open to it where all
of the answers to why someone was
treating me a certain way are like I go
oh that's and it has nothing to do with
me like even I had this really crazy
thing happened so I was sexually
assaulted by one of my teachers in high
school sorry trigger warning but um by
one of my teachers in high school and
one of like the hardest parts was the
year after I graduated I went back to
the high school was a really small
school I had this sort of like Stockholm
syndrome thing like I kept going back to
the school to kind of be like I'm good
it wasn't me like I wasn't the bad thing
and like do you guys still like me even
though the whole school like didn't
really support me and taking this
teacher out and um and I would keep
going back and one of my like most
painful memories was going back and the
teacher
that I had gone to to tell what had
happened to it was to our teachers so
the teacher that had done something to
me and then it was this other art
teacher that I went to and I was like he
did this to me and um he was so mean to
me when I went to the graduation
ceremony the next year he screamed at me
and told me to get out of the room and I
like couldn't understand why would you
be mean to me after this happened like
it just didn't make any sense to me
and then I talked about it on Marc
maron's podcast like three or four years
ago and you know people just randomly
will like DM me having heard it I got a
DM from one of my other teachers from
that time my math teacher and he was
like I don't know if you remember me but
I just listened to your Marc Maron thing
he's like I'm really proud of you he
goes I also want to let you know that
that teacher that was rude to you had I
found out
um he goes I didn't even know he went to
court I would have gone with you to
support you I had no clue he goes he
found out after like all these things
went down that he that that teacher that
was rude to me was the teacher that had
had assaulted me his teacher when he was
in high school there and he had had a
relationship with him oh [__] so he had
been his molester and it's like so he
was lashing out at me because I came for
his like ex-boyfriend or they thought
and the whole school has this weird like
history of this type of [__] well he had
the stock Stockholm syndrome too right
yeah but I have don't forgive him you
don't yeah you don't do that to people
but um I mean I forgive no no I forget
that's not true I forgive him but I
don't excuse that behavior in any way
but he um but there's and then there was
just so many thing other things that
unfolded about that school and it's just
like oh my God I was just like in this
like predator's Den thinking that it was
my fault this whole time and that this
was just this one experience that
happened to me and it was like the whole
Institution
so
Chris Hansen come on anniewood come on
my solopod but it was like he wrote me
this thing and it was just this key to
like this so for for that was for I was
like 15 when that happened 16. and so
I'm like for years have been just
carrying around this like confusion
about it and so now my goal is either to
like ask the universe to give me more of
those answers or to just be settled in
that it is not me and when those things
happen it really does not have to do
with me there's so many like factors
about it that have nothing but you just
can't control to clarify it's like that
that guy yelled at you and then you that
made you feel internalized you it made
you feel like you must have done
something wrong but then I'm so confused
by it too yeah I do to make him
treatment but it's like he had this
whole Affair and other things that I had
no clue about and it was him yelling you
was nothing to do with you yeah and it
was like this missing piece of the whole
thing and there's so many other things
again Chris Hansen let's do this you
ready
um
we have a lot to touch uh at this point
you me and Chris Hanson need to go on
the road I mean
Esther you haven't been diddled that's
fine she rhymes with mustards I'll be
the stage manager
no but that's why I I don't I think I
will not send my daughter to like public
schools at all because that same thing
happened to me so like in so many
different situations and some were
serious than others but like no one did
anything about it people still did this
day like tell me I lied about like my
sexual assets and they were like not
even there and people really came for it
they shame it's like insane I like don't
and it's not like everyone I'm not
saying like don't send your kids about
the school but like I just couldn't I
was an alternative school for troubled
kids so that's another place to be
careful because it's a Target because
the kids are less reliable yeah that's
uh the guy who um I I'm we have we both
went to bhc yeah that was crazy that was
like I had no idea but the bhc is uh is
a psych Hospital right but my the third
time I was in a psych hospital was one
in Torrance and the guy guy who was one
of our counselors there he ended up
asking me out and I ended up dating him
and I was 17 years old and he was in his
30 and I just remember him I the only
image I have of him now is I'm like this
guy wears a lot of Aeropostale I'm like
I don't think he's that cool like all
the girls he yeah
for me was like kids that came over from
Mexico
I used to have Arrow Shirt but he was he
was a Latino but um yeah and I but
that's the thing it's like if I would
have said anything bad they would have
been like no she just tried to kill
herself like she's an unreliable yeah
yeah zero credibility on my own so just
but then also at that time I just didn't
think I was doing anything wrong I was
like oh I'm dating the counselor from
the Side cast but yeah like it feels so
you feel like Chosen and good yeah
because all the girls at the hospital
were like oh he's kind of cute and so
yeah on the last day he was like hey let
me help you pack and I was like I
remember seeing like a Casey and JoJo
song like all my life you know
yeah I'm not here Journey Open Arms
because I got like molested by this
Archer instructor at Club Med this
Casey and JoJo song great that's what's
really are you kidding grow up
that is very gen Z but we're a
Millennials stop playing stop trying to
get your Tick Tock up not on the inside
that was written for his daughter that
song really JoJo song was written for
his daughter and then they were like
that's not like sexy enough so then they
turned it into like a relationship song
oh that's sad but my dad's like tarnish
it like there's not a lot of songs for
Butterfly Kisses
butterfly kisses I love that song that
was great that was a hit in the
Philippines maybe you need to make this
really yeah maybe instead of a boyfriend
this is your dad do you know what I
could give you a dad that's what I would
give you guys know that Ricky Gervais
was a pop icon in the Philippines what
what yeah before he was a stand-up comic
he was part of this um 80s Duo look it
up and they weren't big anywhere in the
world but the Philippines is this why he
has to come so hard for everyone because
he needs to really protect himself from
how embarrassing it is so used to being
a pop star look at this
time oh wow that's cute yum guys being
big over there
you know who else was huge there's
Steven Seagal but I think he was huge
everything no he's not and Pepsi for a
second saw the doc they [__] your feet
Yes [__] they [__] thank you and you
know what I feel like I was one of the
first people who talked about there's a
documentary about how Pepsi ruined my
country but now okay so Pepsi yes I
can't remember what it's called but
Pepsi was doing these like Point systems
and stuff and they had a thing where
they were doing like on caps like there
would be like one out of however many
would be like you get what a million
like yeah a million dollars which in the
Philippines is like huge chain life
changes but they misprinted and everyone
got them oh but then they gave them like
twenty dollars they're like yeah I got
twenty dollars imagine you won Mega your
billion dollars to go make your
Bollywood movie oh my God and they're
like Trisha just kidding here's twenty
dollars
oh my God but but I guess I wouldn't
feel like I was like one chosen as like
everyone was chosen yeah but still would
suck when was that were you over there
but this is also like a third world
country where people are like this is a
third world country yeah and Pepsi has
all that money yeah because and the only
reason they did that is because Coke was
like so prevalent there that they wanted
to come in and Infiltrate The Coke scene
and steel Cola from them and then they
did this [__] thing that was just
like so [__] up thank you so much for
watching the documentary about my
country
it was about a hanger Jet and then
peace about your country though this
other thing how many people are in the
Philippines
um now about 100 million people and how
many of those are your brothers that
you've had about 95.
how do you feel about how the
Philippines are portrayed in like 90 Day
Fiance like big Ed oh my God are you
like really really really really bothers
me not because of
um how they're portrayed it's just this
idea that you can go over there and kind
of exploit someone's
um what do you call it like but I'm a
product of that so I can't say too much
yeah
um my dad was in his mid 50s when he got
with my young 20-something mother and
they had a 36 year age Gap so like I'm
kind of a product of a predatory
relationship my dad had a lot of money
even though he didn't set out to go to
the Philippines to find a wife he was
already living there kind of this
Playboy lifestyle of I come from a rich
family and I'm just gonna go live on the
islands and be this kind of Dawn and
then he met my mom who was like young
and beautiful clearly and who came from
a very poor family he [__] rip but
not yet so it's a little star washing
her clothes
I was like I must have her
but I think there is something you know
like I yeah there's something mutually
beneficial for both I just don't like it
when they're portrayed and like oh she's
only with him for them like what the
[__] do you think he's there for right
right yeah like that somehow that's
disproportionate yes yeah that show is
like unfair to especially like the
foreign people in the relationship they
make them look like so awful and like
it's like but Rose [__] handled him I
love Rose yeah so good she was like [__]
you he's like FaceTiming her still he
has like a I just watched The Reunion
and she's like was on the reunion and
she was yeah he facetimes you all the
time oh my God are you like engaged to
someone else it's like crazy
a big head a big head a big Ed big
Edison he's like your height okay I like
him oh he's got his head goes into his
neck he's a very interesting yeah he's
also just like a disgusting person like
yeah yeah
he's not nice but then he but then he
seemed like for a second like he was
going to be this like kind of like
Fringe guy like helping people that are
like different and stuff and then he's
an [__] yeah he like more than he was
helpful to he's an [__] wife on the
with the yeah on the left is is the
fiance okay yeah oh my gosh look at him
they had like a spin-off show or
something Silver Fox
yeah I can't I cannot watch yeah 90 Day
Fiance does like it triggers me so it is
like Married at First like some of them
like like there's just something you
don't like I love marriage no I watch it
all but Meredith first said I always say
like Married at First sights one of the
shows that like when I play it and fall
asleep and I wake up in the middle of
the night I'm like turn it off turn it
off turn it off like I can't have it
like infiltrating me with my
subconscious like I love it but it Liz
no it's very it's a very interesting
experiment I do yeah I don't watch any
reality TV and I'm now wondering like is
it because I did a reality pilot with
Carlos actually like 12 years ago and I
just saw how everything was so
overproduced that it literally like took
all the love and joy out of it and now I
don't like I never I don't see any of
these I'm like maybe that's a good thing
but I feel like that could be why some
of them some of them you get enough
realness in the moments that you do yeah
it will sustain you over the parts where
you can tell that they're like I do
agree taking a shot or they're like a
lot of the testimonials are like these
people are not good actors so you can
tell that it's they're being so produced
and told exactly yeah but I think I had
this because I grew up watching the
osbornes that was like my favorite show
of all time and it had this like
romanticized view of it and then when we
were doing it Carlos like I remember
they'd be like producers were coming
like okay now you guys are gonna take
tests for your cholesterol and I was
just like oh like we could have just
gotten to this organic
I watched big brother when I started
dating Dave
um because he was into it and I did like
it but that's not over produced because
they're it's just like the testimonials
are so fake yeah well their testimonials
are like wild where you're like they're
like and I'm like Bob you need to Skid
Daddy yeah oh my God I'm gonna tell you
like what to say yeah what reality show
was the context of yours was it like
dating was it like it was just about
like being a like a young female
comedian and like having like a bunch of
guy friends and like what it was like to
be like this was like in 2010 when it
was like oh comedy was still male
dominated the people you would have
highlighted in that show would have been
so funny Carlos Benji Rick did not Andy
no it didn't get picked up do we have
the right last minute I have it
somewhere oh yeah Glassman was in it we
should show some little clippies of it
sure I don't I hate to see you no way
you would hate to see it no
you wouldn't like love like little
Esther a little much yeah like seeing
yourself little Carlos what is what are
your thoughts on this I wouldn't want to
see it either it's like seeing footage
of you from 12 Years Carlos with less
hair weirdly enough
no I had hair I had a little bit on top
it was another Trisha that's what I look
like right now oh I live for it though
thank you he won't he won't take it he
won't I love it he won't quit I love it
thank you you should dread it you ever
think about that I I thought about
getting like white guy braids to be
funny and I was like don't do that yeah
canceled who cares yeah but I kind of
want uh the color hair you have Trisha
yeah it's very like Gerard Way like it's
very cool just to be wild wait Clayton
is bleach blonde right now oh really
yeah maybe you should just connect with
him well last time I reached out to
Clayton he said I didn't have enough
hair for his services oh more money or
town or not town sorry
did you know you cannot well according
to Stanford
um the word trigger warning
um is no longer allowed
so Stanford like put up I think it's
Stanford Stanford why yeah I love that
it's now called a memo so like all of
the like his trigger is triggering this
is from the Stanford
I'm gonna say this again I've said this
everywhere I can possibly say it I say
when I'm triggered I say twigger because
I'm being a baby reminder some say
twigger I'm twiggered and then you go oh
I'm being a child I'm a grown up now
yeah I'm safe I'm good what other words
are canceled Carlos like you can't let
the whole world a lot are yeah yeah the
triggers like deal with what makes if
you get trigger deal with it it's a good
thing is a wonderful tool yeah
instead of addict you never say person
with a substance use disorder addicted
rather they say hooked or devoted
is I'm triggered by this yeah this is
crazy what weird so I was thinking about
this too like the triggering thing like
what you were talking about recently um
like there's no way I could ever just me
I could never protect myself from all
the things that like caused me stress
and chaos and harm like I would have to
like that to me I would be building a
lifestyle where I have to like hide and
knock and then that would trigger you
yeah so it's like I think I'm in a place
where
I just have to learn how to move through
the world and have things trigger me and
control my emotions around but also
negative feelings are useful there's a
reason why we feel them in the same way
that when you touch a fire pain is
useful so you don't touch that fire
again so it's like when I'm feeling
super anxious but it's like it's just my
body saying hey it's an alarm Bell and
probably for a reason sometimes it's not
good for good reason because I have like
anxiety disorder and I get panic attacks
but other times I'm like oh like this
warrants this feeling and I should sit
with it and get to know it and figure
out a way out yeah you know what gives
me that feeling that I didn't realize
this until like last five years when
like all the young people are like
things are triggering us and I was like
oh yeah same but like when I whenever
I've been on like a comedy podcast with
guys and they start talking about like
and then she was blowing me and like the
for some reason the way men talk about
like getting blow jobs from women it
makes me so uncomfortable and I think I
would you maybe used to want to be like
please don't say that for me but I need
to just learn to be like I don't know I
don't know what the answer is but that
definitely does make me uncomfortable
yeah guys with podcasts are cringy like
oh you see it on Tick Tock all the time
like it was that whole like trending
like the energy
entertainment I don't even know any of
these people but it's fun I love it I
don't know and then what are those other
guys like there's another Russian fit
yes those guys too like I just see them
on Tic Tacs I see the thing so it's like
I feel like they have to just try and be
cringy maybe to get like views I don't
know that's the only thing I can think
of why they talk like that because like
nobody I know talks like I think okay so
back in the day
um I used to do girl code and I used to
do a girl code and Guy Code there was
like a girl code versus Guy Code thing
we just did like multiple seasons of it
and on the show The Way They MTV would
produce it sorry MTV I'm spilling your
secrets they would
um you would shoot all like 13 18
episodes I can't remember what it was it
was some sort of odd number but it was
like 13 or 18 15 episodes or something
you would shoot all of them but you
would only get paid for the ones that
you were edited into so I noticed the
guys like Schultz like was so schultzy
back then you know he would say he would
take like the they'll they'll take like
the craziest take because it'll be the
sound bite you know so it's like I think
it like encouraged that sort of right
right I think that's why people do it
like the first law I would never know
them but they just say crazy things and
everyone's reacting and same thing with
the Andrew Tate everyone was like
reacting and I was like I don't know
maybe he's really like I have no idea
but to me I was like oh just give me
like my attention is like what he like
loves yeah but he's also a legit like
human trafficker oh yeah oh he just got
him he just got arrested yeah I didn't
have to find out more of the details I I
don't I haven't been able to find out
too many details about it hi he got
arrested in Romania wait also oh [__]
Greta thornberg
sunberg okay Greta thunberg thank you
Predator
um you know she has dude she's the
climate Okay so she like got in this
fight exchange with him and as I was
looking at her I realized she kind of
looks like Todd oh god I've been putting
my hair extensions on him and bringing
him on stage like putting I go can you
see this a little bit if Tyler's shaved
like they have like kind of the same she
does she not look half asian a little
[__]
just [__] tired she's got like the
round like
close to your lips and obviously a
Bearden is a man but oh my God okay I
have a similar thing there's a female
porn star that looks just like Dave we
look oh my God
Arabella danger I love her no it's a
Bella major and I know why Dave knows
her no I know oh you know her oh is it
because she's Jewish no it's because I
oh my gosh that's different we went from
Greta to Atlanta
because I just introduced that doesn't
look like James oh my God and I'm so
wildly attracted to her can I call you
something yes okay so you introduced me
to one of Dave's best friends yes and I
introduced a Bella danger to him shut up
and he was like she's phenomenal but
then now do you think that he looks at
Dave and sees a similarity whoa we have
to call this she's on our same-sex
friends a little bit we have to call
this out that is so funny
she's always performer of the Year too
she's incredible I love how she like she
rolls her eyes back and she does the
whole I like when she rolls her eyes
back I don't know why she doesn't like
since 1992. oh my God you're missing out
you know I had a little I had like a
couple weeks where I was pouring back I
had um a moment of really big um
obnoxious confidence the other day he
does look like oh my God
by the way that's the funniest ever
posted in the entire world it's so
hilarious the difference
you guys don't have cute babies you have
embryos yeah we have four uh boy embryos
I feel like you want babies just to see
what they like look like together you
know what I mean it's kind of a cool
thing to say anyways well I like it so
he's half asian so that'll be quarter
agent and all of his nieces are so
beautiful
so and the last year Esther and Annie
have really been trying to like hype me
up after the breakup saying you're
beautiful you're stunning you can have
anybody so I had a moment of obnoxious
confidence the other day and I was
talking to this guy that I'm kind of
like seeing and I was like mad Schmidt
and I I don't know like
I had Annie and Esther's voice in my
head and then I was on Instagram while I
was on the phone with him and I scrolled
through a picture of Sofia Vergara like
taking a mirror selfie and so like
without even thinking I was like oh my
God don't I look like Sofia Vergara and
I said that straight to him and he was
like kalila and he just like burst out
laughing and he was like look you're
pretty but like there was the one time
where I needed someone to be like [__]
yeah you know what I see yeah yeah and
he was like nah oh I was like if she was
cross-sided
he wasn't but he was just like look I
think you're beautiful but you're you
ain't that oh my God no she's not hotter
than you you look different than her
she's not hotter than her I can see
similarities though I do similar I
didn't think he's like I have like the
same quality right when I brought when
I'm back after five minutes later yeah
what is that you've got that refugee
release a refugee Refugee and I didn't
but that's my heart meant to say that
when I came back down to earth I was
like okay don't look like her and I
don't know what came over me but it was
both of you guys voices you could get
like slight plastic surgery and look
like her immediately no like slight like
you could like it would take like one I
think My Doppelganger closest because we
have close eyes is probably more
Brittany furlon because our eyes are
like closer set I don't I see Sophie
yeah I do and they both are beautiful
yeah for sure for sure I see it again I
love see that we need to have her on the
show I love her I like
um the the tick tocker who goes to
people and asks them what number they
think they are he goes out of like one
to ten what are you what do you think
you are and then he takes a picture of
them after what they send he asks
someone else what do you think they are
oh I hate it no it's good I like the
[__] that are like I'm an 11. it's
like we should all just do that yeah
that's true it's just better yeah it's
just better no you need someone to Hype
you up like my husband like he gives me
like Grand Illusions all the time like
we watched White Lotus and I was like I
want to be on White Lotus season three
he's like
manifesting it still I can see you on
that oh my God I love you I mean like
there's no way I don't act I don't have
any connections there's just like it's
like the biggest show on HBO but like in
my heart I was like oh I should be on
the show my husband will be like I think
you can do it and I was like okay he's
very much that person and he's like dead
serious too he's like well maybe you
have to come manifest when you [__] and
you try you try to come at the same time
and then manifest and think of the same
thing we really is that a thing I don't
think it's gonna come manifesting but
I've never manifested I've actually
never manifested during sex I like don't
think about it but maybe I should that's
a good time because you're like you're
just like and yeah you're like
otherworldly at that point yeah I don't
know I mean yeah I feel like I feel like
thinking during coming would interrupt
my comments yeah I can
it's a I think that manifesting what I'm
learning more is a feeling it's not a
thinking it's like a like you feel the
feeling of like having the things that
you want right like you can just think
about White Lotus like earlier in the
day and then when you're coming you're
just like you just have the like the
feeling of like how you would feel once
you got this thing you really wanted I
feel like I would just manifest more
coming
it's just all fine thank you more with
me coming thank you so much
um Trisha thank you for joining us today
for our favorite guest ever yeah you fit
in so well oh thanks I love you guys
have guests now they're so fun to watch
like I love the all like the all three
of you guys do but I love the guests
thank you and is there anything we
should know about where to find you next
or any of these future podcasts shout
out your holiday special too oh holiday
special Christmas special on the blonde
Central Farm day Channel and uh I'll be
coming up in season three of Y Lotus on
HBO yeah yeah I agree with Moses I think
yeah you guys thank you so much for
tuning in we will see you next week for
an all new episode don't forget to
subscribe and let us know what you think
about us especially if it's positive bye
[Music]